nfl's 100 season Chris Berman has been
counting down the top 50 plays in NFL
history on Monday night countdown of
course hosting NFL primetime on ESPN
Plus part of the panel to determine the
100 all-time team and now bringing fans
the fastest three minutes during Monday
Night Football
halftime Chris Berman joining us on the
program good morning small how are you
hi Dan good to be with you again it was
great to come back during our
anniversary there on the hour 40 years
old and I didn't know that either of us
for that old but I guess shockingly it's
true so happy holidays now when we were
walking outside that day after we had
our town-hall at ESPN did you have any
idea because where you were with Bob Lee
and did you have any idea that I was
doing sports in there and that night no
protection program no I didn't know
about it till I think the next morning
like they did what I was under orders
that I wasn't allowed to tell anybody
well I tell you what you're coachable
you're coachable I didn't you have a
string where you did at least one
SportsCenter I did I was trying to catch
DiMaggio you know but I came up short I
did I always even long after I did them
as a regular basis or even semi right
you know once we got baseball and you
and Keith were in the 90s I mean I
wasn't on every night like I was in the
80s which was forever but yeah I tried
to come back in May and do one or two
just just to do it and try to pick up a
good weekend to teach the players golf
was usually one of the weekends you know
in May and it was good it was good to go
do it and it you've got me you've talked
about it how did you feel looking back
at it now I'm sure you're glad you I
think you're glad you did I think so I I
wasn't glad that I agreed to it and then
I'm glad that I did it because you know
how this is Chris that the older you get
the better you were and you know our
legacy or legend or whatever you want to
call it you know it's we weren't that
good you know we we were there at the
right time and we we had something that
you know we made something interesting
and different but then to go back and I
just worry that people go I don't get it
you know what's the what's the big deal
about these guys that was what I was
worried about it was just it was nice
though to kind of put a period at the
end of my Sports Center career and go
back do one more show with Keith and
have a little bit of fun and you know
it's like you're back on prime time you
know we're told not to get to me here
I'm not yet although it's sitting with
Tommy is just about beaming every Sunday
night is you were that good you guys you
were every night and people I don't want
to use the word counted on because none
of us are counted on but if we're tuning
in give me some stuff entertain me a
little bit tell me what's going on I
mean we were you were counted on in that
way show and look and people don't get
it if I worried about quoting songs from
my era well they might not get it what
am I going to quote now if you really
want to go there so look we bring you
brought smiles to a lot of people's
faces and you did it again and maybe
that's what we're doing with primetime
although that's a football vehicle on
Sunday nights and then Monday Tuesday
Wednesday all day and all night on ESPN
Plus did it I still believe and you
probably do too that even though you can
oh what happened in the Tampa Atlanta
game let me get it on my phone well
they're the four to three plays I still
feel that people want a meal every now
and then and in pro football I believe
that's true and so for 45 minutes we're
providing a meal if you will the full
meal of the day and I I don't think
those times have come and gone to you
again
no I think what you're finding is there
there's a group of people who in a large
group that grew up with us and they're
probably in their 50s or 60s but then
there's also a younger generation that
is kind of seeing
remembering or being told about and then
they reminisce it feels like anything
that's old becomes new again if that
makes sense so I mean look we were lucky
because back then you tuned into Sports
Center because you didn't know the end
result you might have known the score
but you didn't see the highlights
anywhere so we we had that audience that
came in to us and we were coming off a
Big East game or you know it'd be a
football game or a baseball game on
Sunday night and we had that great
luxury but when you have that audience
this is what I tell you know students
who are you know in my sports casting
school if you get the audience keep the
audience like that that you can get them
how long do you keep them really tells
you know them and yourself how good you
are at what you're doing and we were
able to keep those people for you know a
prolonged period of time longer than we
deserve - right but as you say
everything is coming back are you
wearing bell-bottoms today I remember
when we would we wore shorts on
SportsCenter
oh yeah and then one of the camera
angles was to decide and then somebody
screwed it up because they showed
somebody's legs and then managed because
management didn't know you know we would
come in on the weekend we'd wear shorts
with the you know sneakers and then
somebody you know got a side angle and
then that ruined it for everybody and
then we had where the you know damn
suits all the time yeah I know
that was fun cut short scuttle
opportunities the shorts were shorter
you know when I did it and it was to
crack up the camera people you make them
loose and I have a good time before yeah
they took the wide shot then and then I
think everybody behaved until you guys
proving that we were all the same we we
we poked the bear until the bear bit
right so that was those are the days and
of course we could get away with shorts
then - I want to try it now explain the
the top plays you know the the idea for
that and you know any surprises on that
list well here's the deal so I'm doing
it for TV right this is not a disclaimer
but it's
rather than looking at a list which
you'll when we get all said and done and
I don't want to get into it because
there's some still things left I think
we've done through 12 now we're doing
three and night excuse me three a week
on Monday night countdown and oh by the
way eleven ten nine number eleven you
remember all the others in the top
twenty you go okay yeah of course that's
in there the eleven will will be hmm I
wanted to get one link that was thought
that was a great play I would have never
thought of it but and then the last we
only have 16 Monday night game show and
it gets the 23rd we do five to one and
then Christmas Eve Dan five o'clock we
put them all together for an hour okay
then that will run a few times during
the next week or ten days have you ever
thought about the play that gets lost
because it's set up something yes that's
a good question and so because I'm doing
it for TV right this sometimes I show
while I'm trying to take it okay I'll
give you an example because this is
running I don't remember what number it
is already so Julian Edelman is catch
against Atlanta a few years ago in the
Super Bowl which you remember right but
that never would have happened well that
might have but just a few minutes
earlier Julio Jones had a ridiculous one
right now my play selection if you
really want to make a list is Edelman's
catch but it gave me an opportunity
because again you're watching this on TV
it's if it's just here's a list of 50
and what you're showing 50 plays no no
we have a way to show a hundred if you
will by showing that play and then
Edelman's can despite that Edelman still
made this catch in the Patriots won the
Super Bowl so yes that's a very good
question and TV allows me to veer a
little that if you're just printing a
list you'll see yeah and Julio Jones you
know that that's lost in history on one
of the greatest catches it could turn
out it could have turned out to be one
of the greatest catches
in Super Bowl history because it would
have you would have beaten the Patriots
and but it's it's kind of a lost there
it's it's off to the side because
Edelman's catch and what that meant
because the Patriots won the game but if
Atlanta had won you know that that Julio
Jones catch which was unbelievable in
the moment yep
well here's the thing that I will say -
and it was fun doing it for example I
went back and looked at it Fran
Tarkenton plays right and of course I'm
working with a lot of younger folks yeah
he threw for a lot of yards whoa whoa no
Fran Tarkenton was a little different
okay and you find one when he runs 30
yards backwards into play is really 15
seconds before he releases the ball and
then it's a touchdown but in looking I
found a few more kind of like that and I
went alright so here's the play and I
think Fran that was just recently I had
it was a great combination was a Hail
Mary it was Fran Tarkenton and Brett
Favre so I mean if you want
entertainment for three hole plays there
they are but and that was in the teens I
don't remember the exact numbers not in
front of me
but I felt that after we showed that
play and here's another one just so you
know it was it a fluke one dad going
back again Fran Tarkenton you and I
remember the the early John Mackey I
mean we remember but we didn't see so I
found one when he just clobbered right
and then I found several more I why
don't we show since we have the time
here's the play and then I'm going to
throw in this one as well and by the way
for Jim Brown there were many like it
would guys just obliterated right so
again for TV it's a little different
it's a it's a fun it was a fun exercise
mark Franklin behind the scenes did a
great job as always for me and out of
all of these plays yeah the one game
that you you wish you would have gone to
to have witnessed this in person is
there one that stands out
of the place see now you get interesting
we go well I mean now so I've been too
and let 30 plus Super Bowl so I'll
eliminate those I've seen a lot of those
do we wish that we were well not really
at the Ice Bowl right but do we wish
personally I was at Super Bowl three
when the Jets but there's no play from
that you follow dancing sometimes that
one of the most important games a Super
Bowl three well there's no real and the
top 15 no play from that yes Franco
Harris I would have been there although
I was with so many of name it's games
it's the Immaculate reception for me
well does that led to them they had to
get through Oakland to get to the Super
Bowl well that people forget about that
Dan and is they did not win the Super
Bowl younger that was the start of the
Steelers they they lost to Miami who was
undefeated that was 72 yeah by the way
they used to have a rotation talk about
crazy that championship game was in
Pittsburgh
even though Miami was 14 and old it's
the central I think they have seen
Center everything so it's their turn
what 14 no Miami one anyway in the rest
is history but ya know you look the
Immaculate reception i I like its
chances to be pretty late in the inside
you can see Chris a variety of vehicles
here NFL primetime co-host and the NFL
100 all-time team the top places well
it's great to visit with you please tell
Tommy I said allo Chris and hopefully
we'll cross paths at the Super Bowl all
right thanks for what you me we have a
bull we're having a blast doing
primetime I hope people appreciate it as
much as we like doing it and you're just
there with Keith so you get it thank you
Chris and son Chris Berman for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]